my first uh actual interaction with him
he was at the canteen line and he had
rocks that he had painted and he goes
you want to buy one of my rocks
I want to buy one of your rocks wait you
don't want to buy one of my rocks and he
goes don't you know who I am I'm Charles
Manson I'm more famous than Jesus Christ
[Music]
we arrived there on a gray School Bus
type thing modified school bus called
The Gray Goose
and Folsom looks like a castle and has
a big turret right there at the front
gate and it's uh it's got a big Stone um
Gateway coming in and big iron gates
that slam behind you and just
reverberate through the bus
yeah and uh it really does they tell you
it's the end of the line and it really
does feel like that you can you can feel
the misery in the place you can feel
um the hate and the place you can feel
all these different emotions and uh none
of them are joy and happiness those
don't come into play we come off the bus
the bus drops us off backs up and goes
out
we're standing there in line at the
receiving and re-leasing unit
and we have a sergeant he's walking out
in front there and he says I want to
welcome you all to Folsom State Prison
it's the second oldest prison it was
built in 1880 and he's talking he's
giving us this entry welcome spiel
one of the people that had come up with
us was a very young kid
uh real long hair and stuff and while he
was at Vacaville which had a very large
gay population what they would call
b-cat bees which were the effeminates
and he's got pain and nails and you know
makeup on you stand between me and this
other guy
and as the sergeants walking back and
forth suddenly the gate behind him
coming out of five building slams open
and now comes around this little Mexican
guy running for his life
and just seconds behind was this great
big Mexican guy with a big old knife in
his hand about an 18 inch blade
and
the small guy turns and looks at us for
a moment and runs into the corner of the
yard fence
bounces off and the big guy gets there
and stabs him up now we have Gunners on
the yard they have shotguns and they
have pistols none of them were able to
react fast enough to stop that guy from
stabbing this kid yep but he stabs him
up throws the knife down and waits all
these guards run out and Guff him up
and uh the sergeant without breaking
stride goes and as you notice here at
Folsom State Prison we have unscheduled
extra curriculum activities happening at
any given moment
and the sergeant Goes YouTube pick your
girlfriend up and bring her inside
you could have three stabbings during
your yard time before they'd finally
close the yards make it go back to
yourselves because they would just shut
the art they'd put everybody on the
ground come out pick up the body take
the body away and resume yard
but after the third time they go that's
enough okay everybody go back to
yourselves play time's over
violence was such a a normal thing that
you if it didn't happen for a period of
time you start getting nervous because
that meant something was brewing
um but you'd have uh you'd be trying to
eat chow and we had metal
serving trays where food came out
and uh at that time they gave you metal
forks and metal spoons which of course
people turned into Savvy instruments but
what would they do with the trays they'd
sharpen the tray on the concrete floor
and then they'd fling it across the room
and it would hit you and it could peel a
person's scalp right off their head
um weight piles you go out to the weight
pile you better be really cautious about
who you're working around and working
out with
because nobody would think something
about picking a 40 pound dumbbell up and
smashing your skull with it or smashing
your kneecaps with it I was there
about nine months before I got
transferred to San Quentin and funny
enough one of the people that was there
that I knew
I had known when I was a kid on the
streets
and his name was Doug stenkiewicz and I
knew him I knew him and his family they
were mono Indians I knew his brother
Johnny in 1972 and 1976 the California
Supreme Courts throughout the death
penalty when they reinstated it in 77.
the very first person to go back to
death go to death row was Doug
stankiewicz you know it's one of these
things where you're on the upper yard
and they bring somebody out death row to
take somewhere to medical or something
and they yell everybody face the wall
Dead Man Walking
and you hear the guard saying this and I
always wondered how'd that make the guy
they're walking feel because I knew
every time I'd hear I shuddered because
you know you're telling the guy you know
you're a dead man but with California
unlike Florida and Texas
if you get the death penalty you're far
more likely to die of old age
you know than you are to be put to death
because Doug stanquet's still alive
today even though they have put people
to death did you get into any like
physical altercations in jail and what
would they kind of be about and over
well at Folsom when I first went there I
got into a beef with Aryan Brotherhood
they they always say that they did they
formed up to protect whites from the
blacks and the Hispanics but what I saw
was that they generally victimized the
whites
yeah and uh but it all came down to
power drugs you know and because I
didn't want to be a part of their thing
they didn't appreciate the fact that I
told them yeah I don't need you
initially I was called in to go into the
boxing ring because the idea was if you
went into fight ring the guards
would not you wouldn't get written up no
matter what happened in the ring the
first guy they sent against me was much
larger man than me the problem was he
underestimated me and I ended up putting
him down and
then that made it even worse because now
they're like wait a minute women you
know now we need to know about him and
it became that kind of thing
and uh but it wasn't until I actually
got to San Quentin that uh
they had sent these guys just tried to
stab me up but
I got word I had taped up National
Geographic Magazines around my arms and
and had telephone books made into a stab
vest under my jacket and but even at
that one of the guys had a knife big
enough and strong enough that even when
he did it still went through through the
magazines to stabbed me about an inch
into my arm I got this one of them got
slashed across face by one of the other
guys knives trying to get me you know
and I ended up breaking one of her arms
and we ended up getting this
qualification over with
and I was able to get away without being
caught they had injuries so they of
course got taken to Medical
but the thing is they can't tell because
to tell means that they're going to get
you know pc'd up you know protective
custody because you can't you don't tell
my thing was is that I'm not going to
slap fight which you you trying to come
over here and cause me a problem I'm
gonna try to hurt you and I'm gonna try
to make sure you know you got hurt so
you won't want to come back again and
that's the way it worked out most of the
prisons I was at with the exception of a
cup very few couple
uh there were savings all the time even
at DVI
there were cell killings
two guys beeping to sell one guy got mad
the other guy
kill him and then go to breakfast come
back and tell the cop hey you gotta get
that body out of my cell it's stinking
and that's the first time the cop knows
there's somebody dead in that cell
to be honest like Ed Kemper and I don't
know a lot of people know who he is when
I first saw him walk into the room he
was he was giving us part of our
orientation the second day I was in
prison he was like six foot six six foot
seven 300 pounds and he walked in the
room and the first my first thought was
by if I ever had to fight this man I'd
have to try to kill him because I mean
this guy would this guy was just you
know he he has that kind of weird
ominous presence that he's a danger just
in his way walking in and he spoke to us
in a very monotone thing and one of the
things that got me was when he was
talking to us
he goes every man must have a moral
compass you must not deviate from your
moral compass
and I'm looking at the guy going and you
did what you know I mean you know
where's the moral compass here uh but
luckily with my situation with him is I
only had a couple of minor dealings with
him there and then when I went to work
in the hospital uh he came in one time
and I had to get him into a room to be
to be seen and uh having to go uh would
you come here with me and uh and go over
there and sit down over there and having
him just stare at me with this like
deadpan ice you know it was like he
wasn't and he didn't engage me verbally
he just looked at me you know I was like
oh crap you know but Charlie Manson a
whole different character
I was there about a week and a guy goes
hey you want to meet Charlie Manson you
know what Charlie Manson he goes yeah
he's here he works as a gardener in the
Catholic Chapel Garden
so he took me over to see him
and I saw him from the door I didn't go
actually go in and meet him at that
moment
and quite honestly I was disappointed
and here's this little tiny man
with beard hair he just
and I kept thinking the way everybody
talked about Charlie he would be a
larger man and he wasn't
but my first uh actual interaction with
him he was at the canteen line and he
would have rocks that he had painted he
goes you want to buy one of my rocks
you want to buy one of your rocks well
you don't want to buy one of my rocks
and he goes don't you know who I am I'm
Charles Manson I'm more famous than
Jesus Christ and I'm like yeah okay and
I just ignored him right and again it's
one of those things where he was used to
being somebody that people don't ignore
well
I'm working in the clinic and one of the
things they would do is always trying to
get needles you know and any drugs they
could steal from the clinic well a lot
of times they would go when they
pressure the young guys who were working
there to steal the stuff one day he came
in and he goes look here's a list of
stuff I need I go sorry about your luck
he goes no you don't understand I want
this stuff I don't know what to tell you
and he's like
you've got to learn how how to play this
no I don't
and so he he gets real frustrated and
all of a sudden he just starts screaming
at the top of his lungs and he's still
jumping up on chairs jumping off chairs
and all his staff's running towards him
and I see some of his other friends come
running in they hit one of the med
cabinets real quick and grab a bunch of
stuff run back out
quite honestly having known Tex Watson
and having met Charlie Manson
I've always believed that Tex Watson was
really he
was the force behind the family
Charlie was the head the the figurehead
he made the great little
cartoon character figurehead
but Tex Watson was a very calculated man
because when I met him at California
men's colony
he was the inmate Pastor in the chat in
the Protestant church
he had married a Minister's daughter
uh you know he
he had developed this yoke fellow
following of people
um
you know and and the thing was you got
to remember he was the one that told the
girls Charlie says we've got to do this
well I'm sorry you've got Charlie Manson
you've got Charles Tex Watson Charlie
didn't say which Charlie told him he was
another guy that was highly intelligent
and most of the most of the guys I knew
that were serial killers were just
top-notch intelligence just not
necessarily the guy you want to invite
home for dinner
can you talk a little bit about the lead
up to being released and what happened I
I've been to nine parole hearings
and I kept being denied denied denied
and part of their argument was that I
would be deported and they thought that
well I would just not be able to fit in
over here so I've become a massive
criminal over here
um
2013 I went to before a parole board and
I got found suitable and it went before
the governor and the governor was Jerry
Brown who had been a governor back in
the 70s and back then he gave up the
prisoners Bill a right and gave a lot of
inmates rights that we didn't they
didn't took away later
and he said no
and uh
he didn't give me a reason so we asked
and he said because I can't and I argued
in court that
because I can is not illegal it's not a
legal
reason you know I mean that's just
that's like a mean reason so it took me
four more years to get found suitable
again
they uh they tried to fly me home on
British Airways because it'd be a
Non-Stop
but British Airway wouldn't let me be
Shackled
so he's brought me on Delta and I had
waste chains and handcuffs on
and we went to the Sacramento Airport
and they uh they threw a sweatshirt over
my hands says don't try not to look out
of ordinary I've got two guys in suits
holding my arms and my hands are like
this with a sweatshirt over it we landed
in Heathrow
they had taken all the stuff anything I
had at the prison which was over two
thousand dollars they took from me to
pay for my detention
I was given a five pound note
uh walked up to the Border people
customs man comes out to me shakes my
hand asks me how I'm doing so I'm doing
well looks at my documents says how long
you've been gone since 64 years he goes
why are you back at some home he goes
yes you are he goes now just walk right
down there to pick up your bags and uh
head on out but yeah I started my life
over here again you know February 13
2018 with five pounds in my pocket and
told never to come back to the U.S but
uh quite honestly I don't have a he
desired to do that
what's been the hottest thing about kind
of adjusting to the whole new country
and then also just back to freedom I
don't know if I'm ever going to fully be
able to
feel like I've I've you know I would
have been had I grew up over here I
don't have mates over here in the in the
UK yet I've been here coming up on five
years and I've yet to actually
develop the relationship where I just
have some guys I can go out and shoot
pool with it's one of these things where
things I do I do myself I go to the gym
by myself I work out by myself
um I've been to a few pubs where there
are pool tables I shoot pool by myself I
don't know how I don't know how to
explain it but I can't I don't connect
but
um like I said I
you know I've gotten to where I have a
contentment and a piece about me that I
wish I wasn't sure I'd ever find I I
have to say my life is good
um
do I do I not appreciate the fact I'm 68
and getting ready to turn 69 you betcha
I'm a dinosaur I know I'm a dinosaur
I'm just trying to be a happy dinosaur
[Music]
and um
my wife's car is not there it's like 11
30 at night
no lights are on in the house and we
always left the light on if I'm out and
um
walked in
I have a man who is stretched out on my
floor
I checked him and he was dead